Muy bien. Como ya saben, en
nuestro análisis avanzamos
a la pregunta del tipo de estructuras
sociales que son legítimas
o contribuyen al bienestar de
los seres humanos,
dada nuestra naturaleza.
Terminamos la última conferencia
con una representación
de la teoría de juegos de lo que llamo
el dividendo de cooperación,
que recordarán supone el caso
de dos personas que,
temerosos de que el otro
ataque sus recursos,
emplean cierta cantidad de
energía encerrando sus bienes.
Dónde estarían para
encontrarse en una situación
en la que podrían cooperar y
confiar entre sí en cooperar,
podrían dedicar su energía, en
lugar de proteger sus bienes,
a proteger otros tipos de bienes.
Los que se requieren, dice Hobbes,
"para vivir con amplitud"
y para cosas como la navegación.
Los bienes les permitirían a
los dos vivir mejor.
Y en las últimas dos clases vimos
los escritos de Thomas Hobbes
en el contexto de su trabajo, el
Leviatán, que exploró tanto la razón
por la que se espera que el
dividendo de la cooperación
sea ventajoso para todos
y por qué es apropiado tener la
cooperación en su lugar, ciertos tipos
de mecanismos de cumplimiento
externo: en la mente de Hobbes,
a un Leviatán, un monarca o líder
que tiene poder absoluto,
se le exige contar con este
tipo de cooperación.
En esta clase y el próximo jueves
veremos una versión contemporánea
de esta pregunta, que nos
pide que pensemos:
si no consideramos la
simple cooperación
o falta de ésta entre dos personas,
sino más bien la distribución de
bienes y responsabilidades
en una comunidad mayor:
de qué manera se
estructuraría dicha
sociedad
si tomamos como nuestra imagen
básica algo similar a Hobbes.
Es decir, la idea de la
cooperación es benéfica para
todos
en una forma en que la
competencia no lo es,
pero que la cooperación que
promueve la estabilidad
requiere ciertos tipos de incentivos.
Hoy veremos en particular la discusión
del filósofo del siglo XX John
Rawls, que vivió de 1921 a 2002,
y que durante toda su carrera
dio clases en Harvard.
Encontramos escritos de Rawls en uno
de sus primeros documentos,
el de 1955 sobre el castigo que vimos
cuando presentamos la idea
de una justificación de dos
niveles del castigo.
En la clase de hoy veremos en
análisis de Rawls
en su libro de 1971, Una
teoría de justicia,
que tuvo una enorme influencia.
Así, la Teoría de la
justicia de Rawls,
que en muchas formas regresa
a la consideración
de la discusión filosófica
contemporánea de un conjunto de
preguntas
que rastreamos hasta la
República de Platón:
por qué está en el mejor
interés de las personas
participar en una estructura social,
y que se toma en una forma que
entró en el discurso público.
Una teoría de justicia es
el tipo de libro
que se cita en los casos legales.
Verán que se discute no solo en
publicaciones académicas,
sino también en conversaciones
con bases intelectuales
acerca de la legitimidad de la sociedad.
Una teoría de la justicia comienza
con estas famosas palabras.
Rawls dice, después de expresar lo
que espera hacer con el libro,
que la "Justicia es la primera virtud
de las instituciones sociales,
como la justicia lo es de los
sistemas de pensamiento".
Dice, "del mismo modo que una
teoría, sin importar lo elegante
y económica que sea, debe rechazarse
o revisarse si no es verdad,
así las leyes e instituciones,
sin importar lo eficientes o bien
organizadas que estén,
deben reformarse o abolirse
si son injustas".
Esta es una expresión de
lo que Rawls ve
como el compromiso central de
una cierta perspectiva
de la legitimidad del gobierno.
Una imagen occidental, y quizá
la imagen más general,
de acuerdo con la cual una
estructura social,
un conjunto de
instituciones
fundamentales
por las que se rigen las vidas,
es legítima si y solo si las
instituciones que soporta son justas.
Así como una teoría
extraordinariamente elegante,
pero falsa, deberá
rechazarse por no ser verdad,
también, dice Rawls, debe
rechazarse una estructura social
que es elegante pero injusta.
Sigue adelante
identificando lo que
percibe
como algunos compromisos
fundamentales de este tipo de
imagen.
Por ejemplo, escribe que
"cada persona posee una
inviolabilidad basada en la justicia
que
ni siquiera el bienestar de la
sociedad como un todo puede anular.
Por esta razón, la justicia niega
que la pérdida de libertad para
algunos se vuelve correcta
por el bien mayor que
comparten los demás".
Ahora pensemos en esta pregunta,
la negociación de bienes entre
personas, en el contexto
de nuestro análisis del
consecuencialismo por un lado,
y otras teorías morales,
la deontología y la teoría de
la virtud por el otro.
Lo que Rawls expresa, tanto aquí
como en las secciones 5 y 26
de la Teoría de justicia,
que les pedí leer,
es otra razón relacionada
con lo que leímos
en Bernard Williams, de esta
idea de dignidad.
Otra razón para rechazar como
una forma fundamental
de que la responsabilidad
humana tenga sentido;
el consecuencialismo como su cimiento.
Pero lo que podría no ser
aparente para ustedes,
cuando leamos cosas como el
problema del carrito,
fue la conexión de esta perspectiva:
la idea de que "cada persona
posee una inviolabilidad
basada en la justicia que ni siquiera
el bienestar de la sociedad
como un todo puede anular",
y uno de los documentos sobre los
que se fundó esta nación.
Así, entre las verdades que Thomas
Jefferson creyó que tenemos
como "evidentes por sí mismas", es que
"todos los hombres fueron
creados iguales
y gozan de ciertos derechos inalienables
que les confirió su creador.
Entre ellos":
estos derechos, que ni siquiera la
utilidad de la sociedad
como un todo es suficiente para anular,
"son la vida, la libertad y la
búsqueda de la felicidad".
Además, verán en este
documento fundacional,
por supuesto, se trata de la
Declaración de Independencia,
que hay una voz que se da exactamente
a la imagen que transporta
un contrato que primero reconocemos
en su forma rudimentaria
en la discusión de Glaucón de la
función de la justicia
en la República de Platón
y de manera mucho más clara en
el trabajo de Hobbes.
Escuchen lo que sigue.
"Que para garantizar esos derechos,
se instituyen gobiernos
entre los hombres
que derivan sus justos poderes del
consentimiento de los gobernados".
La idea de que entrar en un
contrato social con otra persona,
por medio del cual como forma de
asegurar los derechos a la vida,
la libertad y la búsqueda de
felicidad, nos sujetamos
al mandato de la ley, que por lo
tanto consideramos legítima,
es central, tanto a la tradición del
contrato social como lo expresan
Hobbes y sus sucesores
Locke, Rousseau y Kant,
como para este documento,
que supongo que todos
encontramos previamente.
Además, continúa el documento,
"siempre que alguna forma de gobierno
se vuelve destructiva de estos fines,
las personas tienen el derecho
de alterarla o abolirla,
y de instituir un nuevo gobierno".
¿Qué tipo de nuevo gobierno?
¿Cuál es la respuesta de Jefferson?
Un nuevo gobierno, en donde "establecer
las bases de tales principios
y organizar sus poderes de tal forma
que les parezca que tiene
mayor probabilidad
de afectar su seguridad y felicidad".
Así, la idea que propusimos
de crear un gobierno
que reciba su legitimidad
del reconocimiento
que se otorga por nuestro
interés propio,
es una noción central de la
tradición política estadounidense.
Así, ¿de qué manera se
manifiesta a sí mismo
en el texto particular que
analizamos hoy?
¿De qué manera John Rawls, en su
libro de la década de 1970,
pretende dar una voz contemporánea a
este conjunto de preocupaciones
que 200 años antes expresó
Thomas Jefferson,
y 150 años antes hizo lo
propio Thomas Hobbes?
Rawls comienza diciendo qué le toma
a la sociedad ser lo que es.
La sociedad, para la que
tratamos de identificar
como un conjunto de características,
es "una asociación más o menos
suficiente de personas que,
en sus relaciones entre sí
reconocen como vinculantes
ciertas reglas de conducta"
y que, "en su mayor parte,
actúan de acuerdo con ellas".
Recordarán, al final de la clase
del dilema del prisionero
la semana pasada y en nuestras
lecturas para el jueves pasado,
que observamos otros mecanismos
distintos de los que Hobbes
identificó para el
cumplimiento del contrato
social.
Hobbes pensó que la forma más eficaz
era la imposición de un soberano,
cuya amenaza de castigo y sanciones
haría que las personas se
condujesen de cierta manera.
Pero resulta ser, además,
que tomarlas de manera implícita a
través de la consciencia
o hábito de cierto tipo de
normas de interacción
termina desempeñando una función
tan grande, si no mayor,
al permitir a las sociedades
funcionar sin problemas.
En las lecturas del próximo martes
veremos algunos trabajos
de psicología social que abordan
directamente esa pregunta.
Así, Rawls nos dijo lo que
piensa que es una sociedad,
para propósitos de discusión.
Es "una asociación más o menos
autosuficiente de personas que,
en sus relaciones entre sí
reconocen" algo,
es decir "ciertas reglas de
conducta, como vinculante"
y, "en su mayor parte", no siempre,
sé que algunos de ustedes hablan por
el celular mientras manejan,
"actúan de acuerdo con ellas".
Estas reglas "especifican un sistema
de cooperación diseñado"
¿para hacer qué?
Está diseñado para hacer lo
que Thomas Jefferson
decía en la Constitución.
Está diseñado para hacer
lo que Thomas Hobbes decía
en el Leviatán.
Está diseñado para hacer
lo que Glaucón decía al
cuestionar a Sócrates.
Especifican "un sistema de
cooperación diseñado
para promover el bien de
quienes toman parte en él".
La legitimidad del gobierno en esta
imagen se deriva del hecho
que es para la ventaja de
quienes participan en él.
Sin embargo, y esta es la
característica desconcertante
que hace que la filosofía política
sea una disciplina de gran
interés intelectual,
"si bien la sociedad es una empresa
cooperativa para la ventaja
mutua", está, dice, Rawls, de
manera innegable y típica,
"marcada por el conflicto al igual que por
la identidad de los intereses".
¿Por qué?
Porque si bien existe una
identidad de intereses,
debido a que la cooperación
social permite una mejor vida
para todos de la que tendrían si cada
uno viviera de manera exclusiva
por su propio esfuerzo.
Es decir, percibimos dividendos
como consecuencia de no tener que
expandir nuestra energía
al protegernos de la amenaza
del daño de los demás.
Cada uno de nosotros, como lo
sabemos por nuestras últimas
dos clases, está mejor cuando puede
contar con que los demás
serán cooperativos.
Sin embargo, hay un conflicto de
intereses en cualquier sociedad,
ya que "las personas no son indiferentes
en cuanto a la forma de
distribuir los mayores beneficios
de su colaboración".
Hablando en términos amplios,
todos prefieren una
participación mayor a una
menor.
Si hay dividendos por la cooperación,
es bueno y produce una razón
para la cooperación.
Pero cuando hay dividendos
de la cooperación,
cada uno de nosotros, de
manera bastante razonable,
quiere tanto de los dividendos
como pueda obtener.
Y la consecuencia de esto
es que si bien la
"sociedad es una empresa
cooperativa para ventaja mutua",
de manera típica "está
marcada por el conflicto
tanto como por la
identidad de intereses".
Esto da origen a la pregunta
del nivel siguiente.
Cuando leímos a Hobbes,
leímos solamente el inicio de su
análisis del contrato social,
apenas un poco del final del libro uno
y el comienzo del libro dos.
Ahora, Rawls recurre a una
pregunta más allá de eso.
Es decir, ¿a qué conjunto de
principios deberíamos adaptarnos
en caso de un conflicto?
Hablamos como algo implícito que
queremos cooperación,
algún tipo de estructura social.
Como resultado,
terminaremos con más
cosas
de las que habríamos tenido si
no hubiéramos cooperado.
¿De qué manera deben distribuirse
esas cosas, esos bienes:
unos tangibles, otros intangibles?
Rawls señala que se requiere un
conjunto de principios
para escoger entre diversos
arreglos sociales,
que determinan las ventajas de
esta distribución.
Estos principios "son una forma de
asignar derechos y obligaciones
en las instituciones
básicas de la sociedad".
Cosas como la apariencia
del sistema legal.
Cosas como la apariencia del
sistema económico.
Cosas como la apariencia de los derechos
y responsabilidades
fundamentales de los
ciudadanos.
Y lo que hacen es definir una
distribución apropiada
de los beneficios y las cargas de
la cooperación social.
Porque, como ya observamos, la
cooperación social trae consigo
innegables beneficios, así como
ciertos tipos de cargas.
En un sistema de cooperación,
su libertad se limita en ciertas formas.
Esto podría ser el caso que los
beneficios acumulados
en el sistema social van a
otras personas.
Así, estamos en un punto en el que
expresaré lo que Rawls llama
la idea principal de la
teoría de la justicia.
Y luego les explicaré de
qué manera esto encaja
con su noción del velo
de la ignorancia.
Y luego, cuando su atención
comience a disiparse,
haremos algunos ejercicios
con marcadores.
Quédense con nosotros y
tendrán más hechos
y algo de diversión.
La idea principal de La
teoría de justicia,
como ya señalamos,
es algo que forma parte de la
tradición del contrato social.
Rawls dice explícitamente,
en la primera nota al pie del
texto que leímos para hoy,
que trabaja de manera primaria desde
la imagen del contrato social
como la expresan Locke, Rousseau y
Kant, pero que evocan a Hobbes.
Como saben, la idea siguiente es
que cada uno de nosotros reconoce
que existe cierta ventaja
por vivir en una sociedad
en la que estamos
constantemente bajo amenaza,
que cada quien reconoce que puede
lograrse la no amenaza;
esta idea de que ustedes están
constantemente bajo riesgo
en esta guerra fría de
todos contra todos.
Que la no amenaza puede lograrse
solamente bajo cooperación.
Que la cooperación general
puede lograrse solamente
bajo cierto tipo de sistema de
cumplimiento implícito o explícito.
Así, Rawls, teniendo en mente el
marco del contrato social,
pregunta qué se necesitaría para
obtener una imagen clara
de cómo sería el sistema de
cumplimiento si, como recordamos,
significa ser algo para el bien de
cada uno de los participantes.
Esto es lo que dice:
Dice, "Los principios de la justicia",
de la estructura básica de la sociedad,
"son aquellos que las personas
libres y racionales,
que se preocupan para ampliar
el interés propio,
aceptarían en una posición
original de igualdad,
como la definen los términos
fundamentales de su asociación".
Que hay cuatro ideas
fundamentales bajo esta imagen.
Las reglas que rigen su sociedad,
las que rigen una sociedad legítima,
con la que debería contratarse,
son las reglas que aceptarían si
ustedes fueran libres, racionales,
con un interés propio y en una
posición de igualdad
con respecto de todas las demás
personas libres, racionales
y con intereses propios que también
contratan en esta sociedad.
¿Cómo es posible que lleguemos ahí?
¿Cómo podemos determinar qué
personas libres, racionales,
con interés propio e iguales
estarían de acuerdo en que, de
hecho, no somos iguales?
Algunos nacemos en familias ricas
y otros lo hacemos en familias pobres.
Algunos nacemos con ciertos
conjuntos de talentos naturales;
otros tienen otros talentos.
Algunos nacemos con ciertos
tipos de concepciones,
y otros fuimos educados para tener
ciertos tipos de concepciones,
de la buena vida.
Otros fuimos educados para
tener otros conceptos.
La idea de Rawls es la siguiente:
los principios que articulan
la estructura legítima de la sociedad
son aquellos con los que
ustedes estarían de acuerdo
si no supieran el tipo de
personas que van a ser.
Así, les pide que imaginen que
están detrás de lo que llamó
un "velo de ignorancia",
en el que nadie conoce su lugar en la
sociedad, su posición social,
su fortuna en la distribución
de activos y pasivos,
su inteligencia, su fuerza o la
concepción del bien.
Desde esta posición, cuando no
saben qué persona serán,
obtienen el último de nuestros
cuatro requerimientos.
Obtienen igualdad.
Porque nada en particular sobre
sus propios intereses
desempeñará una función.
Habiéndose puesto en esta
posición imaginaria,
donde la ignorancia trae consigo
un cierto tipo de habilidad de
pensar claramente la pregunta,
cada parte determina libremente
con base en su interés propio racional.
Eso nos da libertad,
racionalidad e interés propio.
El marco que creen que sería mejor.
Así, la idea es esta: un
montón de personas
que no saben qué función
desempeñarán en una sociedad
se sientan detrás de un velo de
ignorancia y piensan:
¿cómo querría que la
sociedad se estructurara
si no sé si voy a terminar como
pastor o como capitalista,
médico o albañil, policía
o alguien que tiene dificultades con
las autoridades de policía,
o bien alguien con
capacidades diferentes,
o incluso un jugador de
fútbol americano de Yale?
Y detrás de ese velo de ignorancia,
reconocer que alguna de
estas identidades
podría terminar siendo la
persona que habría de ser,
estas personas proponen un
marco de cómo es
que se estructura la sociedad.
Así, al reconocer que podrían ser
extraordinariamente ricos,
pueden tomar en cuenta lo que
requiere la sociedad
para permitir a las personas
florecer bajo esas condiciones.
Pero al mismo tiempo podrían
reconocer que pueden terminar
como uno de los trabajadores
de la construcción.
Quizá terminen como médicos.
Tal vez el conjunto de
habilidades que tenían
difiere del de la mayoría de
la sociedad, etcétera.
Entonces, lo que tienen en la
articulación del velo de la ignorancia
como forma de pensar en esta pregunta,
en la versión de Rawls de un tema
que hemos visto una y otra
vez en este curso.
Hobbes dice: Cuando piense en
estructuras políticas,
piense en sí mismo como
diferente de cualquier persona.
Esté dispuesto, dice, "a
ceder sus derechos
en la medida en que los
demás quieran hacerlo".
Conténtese con tanta
libertad contra los demás
como la que los demás
tienen contra usted".
Mill dice, "las acciones son correctas
en la proporción que tienen
para promover la felicidad, y
erróneas en tanto tienden a producir
lo inverso de la felicidad.
No la propia felicidad del agente,
sino la de todos los involucrados".
Kant, una vez más expresando la idea:
cuando uno piensa desde la
perspectiva moral,
no lo hace de sí mismo como
especial, escribe.
"Actué solo de acuerdo con esa máxima
a través de la cual al mismo tiempo se
convertirá en ley universal".
Así, si sacan sus marcadores,
haremos tres rápidos ejercicios
en los que veremos si la
estrategia de Rawls funciona.
Permítanme explicarles cómo funciona.
En este caso, están decidiendo
si se inscriben en una de las
tres secciones del curso.
Así, las clases del curso serán
idénticas en los tres casos.
Pero en la primera opción, el curso
tiene cuatro excelentes secciones,
que los estudiantes califican
en promedio con 9/10.
Así, cuatro de las secciones son
excelentes y una es terrible.
Ustedes no saben en qué
sección van a terminar.
Así, en la primera opción, tienen
la opción de ir a clases
y se les asignará de manera
aleatoria a una de las secciones.
Cuatro de ellas son
excelentes y una es terrible.
La segunda opción es que
pueden tomar el curso
y cuatro de las secciones
son muy buenas:
en promedio, recibieron una
puntuación de 7/10;
y una de las secciones es terrible.
No saben en qué sección van a estar.
Así, si toman esto, tienen
una posibilidad de 4/5
de estar en una muy buena sección,
pero 1/5 de estar en una terrible.
En la tercera versión del curso,
cuatro de las secciones son muy buenas.
Obtienen 7/10.
Y una de las secciones es regular.
La pregunta es, ¿qué curso toman?
¿Se inscriben en el curso que tiene
cuatro secciones excelentes
y una terrible?
Recuerden que so saben en qué
sección van a estar.
¿Se inscriben en el curso que tiene
cuatro secciones muy buenas
y una terrible?
¿O se inscriben en el curso que tiene
cuatro secciones muy buenas
y una regular?
¿Todos tiene clara la
estructura de la pregunta?
Comienzo la votación.
Muy bien. Muy bien, adelante.
Veamos.
Muy bien, 60% de ustedes
están con... ¡guau!
¿Dónde están mis valores atípicos?
¡Muchachos! ¡Todos
entendieron! ¡Sorprendente!
Para quienes nos visitan,
en esta clase nunca hemos
tenido 0% de personas
que elijan mi opción
obviamente irracional.
Me da gusto ver que presumir los
días previos a Yale,
las personas hacen un buen trabajo.
Así, aproximadamente a 60% de
ustedes les gusta tomar riesgos.
Están dispuestos a tomar
el riesgo de 1/5
de estar en la clase terrible.
Pero 40% de ustedes evaden el
riesgo en este contexto.
Probemos de nuevo.
Exactamente la misma pregunta,
pero distinto escenario.
Este es el escenario: entran a un
a lotería de vivienda
y pueden entrar en la lotería
uno, en la dos o en la tres.
La lotería de vivienda uno,
hay cuatro cuartos
excelentes y uno terrible.
La lotería de vivienda dos,
hay cuatro cuartos muy
buenos y uno terrible.
La lotería de vivienda tres,
hay cuatro cuartos muy
buenos y uno regular.
Una vez más, no saben
dónde terminarán.
Pregunta,  ¿entran a la
lotería de vivienda uno,
dos o tres?
Pongamos el cronómetro.
Seis, cinco, cuatro, tres, dos, uno.
Veamos qué obtuvimos.
¡Ajá! No les importa la clase,
pero evaden mucho el
riesgo en la vivienda.
Así, cuando se trata de su bienestar
en términos de la
infraestructura en la que
viven,
68% de ustedes está dispuesto a
renunciar a la posibilidad
de un cuarto excelente
por la certidumbre
de que no terminarán en un
cuarto que es terrible.
Probemos una vez más.
Ahora van a ir a un hospital.
Esta es la configuración.
Hospital uno: cuatro médicos
excelentes, uno terrible.
Hospital dos: cuatro médicos
muy buenos, uno terrible.
Hospital tres: cuatro médicos
muy buenos, uno regular.
Están pidiendo una ambulancia para
que los lleve a urgencias.
No saben qué médico está de turno,
pero saben que el hospital uno
tiene cuatro médicos
excelentes y uno terrible.
El hospital dos tiene cuatro médicos
muy buenos y uno terrible.
El hospital tres tiene cuatro
médicos muy buenos y uno regular.
Veamos cuáles son los
resultados esta vez.
Cuatro, tres, dos, uno.
Veamos en dónde se acomodaron.
Así, cuando se trata de decisiones
médicas de alto riesgo,
evaden el riesgo incluso más
que con la vivienda.
¿Qué tanto más importante
que cualquiera de estas decisiones
locales es la decisión global?
¿Qué tipo de marco social
quieren en torno a ustedes
si no saben qué función
desempeñarán?
Así, la pregunta de Rawls de
qué sociedad escogen,
está dirigida para ser una
versión de esas tres preguntas,
que acabo de hacerles.
¿Qué sistema médico eligen
si no saben con qué tipo de
persona estarán?
La respuesta fue: eligieron una
que llegó a ser muy buena,
pero terminó siendo regular.
¿Qué sistema de vivienda escogen?
¿Qué sistema educativo escogen?
Esos fueron los casos especiales para
la pregunta que Rawls hace.
¿Qué sociedad escogen desde detrás
del velo de la ignorancia?
Rawls es muy claro en cuanto a que
la sociedad que escogen
tiene dos compromisos básicos.
El primero es que cuando
contratamos un marco social
que regirá todos los
aspectos de nuestras vidas,
la primera condición es que,
dentro de dicho marco,
cada persona tendrá un "derecho
igual al sistema total
más extenso de libertades
básicas iguales
compatible con un sistema de
libertades similares para todos".
Es decir, cada uno de nosotros tiene
derechos iguales para votar,
para ser electo, libertad de expresión,
de asociación, de
conciencia, de pensamiento,
de persona; derecho a tener
propiedades y libertad
de ser tratados iguales con respecto
del ministerio de la ley.
Éstos, dice Rawls, no son
negociables y no lo son
en el sentido de que, si se los
ofrecemos a ustedes,
desde detrás del velo de la ignorancia,
la posibilidad de intercambiar
algunos de estos bienes en
nombre de la utilidad,
si o saben qué persona
serán en esa sociedad,
o entrarían a ese intercambio.
Esta es la forma en que Rawls
intenta derivar estos
principios inviolables,
que vimos al principio de la
Declaración de Independencia,
de la idea de que son
líneas en la arena
que podrían dibujarse en
cualquier marco social
en el que se registrarían las
partes libres, racionales,
con interés propio e iguales.
Esa es la primera respuesta de
Rawls a la pregunta,
¿qué sociedad escogen?
Escogen una que tiene una
línea base no negociable
en el nivel de regular o mejor,
con respecto de estas
libertades fundamentales.
Estas son las cosas que no se
negocian por nada.
Además, y en cierto modo con mayor
controversia, dice Rawls,
ustedes, detrás del velo
de la ignorancia,
apoyarían una estructura social
en la que la distribución de las
desigualdades sociales y económicas
seguía cierto conjunto de limitaciones.
La primera es que, en la
medida que surgen
las desigualdades sociales y
económicas en esa sociedad,
necesitan unirse a puestos y
empleos abiertos a todos
bajo condiciones de igualdad
justa de oportunidades.
Si asistir a una institución
educativa excelente
aumenta la probabilidad de que
puedan obtener un empleo,
en el que obtengan satisfacción
y perciban una parte desproporcionada
de los recursos de la sociedad,
entonces tiene que ser el caso,
dice Rawls, que esos puestos,
esas oportunidades, están
abiertos para todos
independientemente de las
contingencias de circunstancia
que son irrelevantes a la
posibilidad de usarlos.
En particular, los recursos
financieros de su familia
no deberíanº tener una participación
en su capacidad de tener acceso
a estas oportunidades.
Así, una igualdad justa de oportunidad
es la primera condición que
Rawls cree necesitar
a fin de que las desigualdades
sociales y económicas
sean aceptables para ustedes,
detrás del velo de ignorancia
cuando no saben quiénes
llegarán a ser.
Además, y aún más controversial,
Rawls piensa que detrás del
velo de ignorancia,
las partes deberían convenir que
las desigualdades sociales
y económicas se aceptarían como
legítimas solamente en la medida
que dichas desigualdades son
una ventaja para todos.
En particular, en la ventaja de aquellos
que están, por lo menos,mejor.
Rawls no niega que una marea en
alza eleva todos los barcos,
que muy bien puede haber casos en los
que permitir las discrepancias
en el ingreso o los recursos, las
oportunidades de educación
o la calidad de la atención a la salud
llevarían de hecho a
todos a estar mejor.
Tal vez el hecho de que haya
hospitales de investigación
es de gran valor, incluso para
aquellos que no tienen
acceso directo a dichos hospitales.
No obstante, es porque, y solo porque,
estas desigualdades benefician
a los que están peor,
que Rawls piensa que convendrían
detrás del velo de la ignorancia.
Además, Rawls piensa que estos
principios, que yo expresé:
el primer principio, el de
libertad igual;
y el segundo, que nos dice
las condiciones
bajo las cuales la
desigualdad es legítima,
son lo que llama "ordenados
lexicológicamente",
de modo que no se permitan
negociaciones utilitarias.
En particular, no hay libertad de
negociación para la utilidad.
Sería ventajoso para la
sociedad como un todo
participar en cierta forma de
perfil racial, por ejemplo,
para reducir los índices
de criminalidad,
pero al hacerlo se afectarían las
libertades de cierto grupo,
así que la consideración de utilidad
no es suficiente, dice Rawls.
Además, como señalamos, en
la imagen de Rawls,
la desigualdad se permite
solo cuando la ventaja
va a los más desfavorecidos.
Así, en los últimos 3 o 4
minutos de la clase,
quiero hacer dos encuestas
más con ustedes.
Así, si tienen sus
marcadores a la mano,
quiero conocer sus
pensamientos respecto de
esto.
Y si éstos son diferentes
de los de Rawls,
voy a darles cuatro lugares para
identificar el lugar del desacuerdo.
Comencemos con esto.
Tratan de escoger entre sociedades.
La sociedad 1 tiene un ingreso
promedio de $100,000
y 85% de sus ciudadanos
tienen derecho a votar
y libertad de conciencia y
religión, etcétera.
Es decir, es una sociedad en la
que 15% de las personas
carece de los derechos civiles básicos,
pero el ingreso promedio es de $100,000.
La sociedad 2 tiene un ingreso
promedio de $70,000
y 15% de las personas carece
de derechos básicos.
La sociedad 3 tiene un ingreso
promedio de $70,000,
pero 100% de las personas
tiene derechos básicos.
Están detrás del velo de ignorancia.
No saben si estarán en el 15%
de las sociedades 1 o 2.
Como cuestión de racionalidad libre,
igual y con interés propio,
¿qué sociedad escogen?
Uno, dos o tres.
Veamos cuáles son los
resultados esta vez.
Parece que, como la prioridad
lexicológica del primer principio
sobre el segundo es aquella en la que
no hay grandes controversia.
Probemos el principio de diferencia.
Tres sociedades.
No saben cuál será.
Sociedad número uno: ingreso
promedio de $100,000.
Ingreso más bajo: $10,000.
Sociedad número dos: ingreso
promedio de $70,000;
ingreso más bajo: $10,000.
Sociedad número tres: ingreso
promedio de $70,000;
ingreso más bajo: $20,000.
No saben quién serán.
¿Qué sociedad eligen?
Veamos los resultados esta vez.
Muy bien.
Así, todavía, eh.
No hay tanta diferencia
como yo esperaba.
Es interesante ver que la
mayoría de ustedes,
incluso aquí, son igualitarios.
Opuestos a un aumento en el promedio
si es a costa de los
menos privilegiados.
Así, para aquellos de ustedes
que están en el 27%
y para quienes de manera más general
no aceptan el marco de Rawls,
quiero señalar cuatro
lugares diferentes
en los que podrían separarse de él.
El primero es que podrían estar
en desacuerdo con él
sobre los tipos de principios
que se elegirían detrás del
velo de ignorancia.
Podrían pensar que el
razonamiento minimax;
recuerden que en la
sección 26 dice que,
detrás del velo de ignorancia, las
personas evitan el riesgo.
Distribuirían bienes de tal forma
en que se beneficiarían
los que están peor.
Así, podrían negar que detrás
del velo de ignorancia,
los principios que Rawls dice
que se escogerían,
lo serían.
Podrían negar que es la
elección que no hace detrás
del velo de ignorancia que
representa qué personas libres,
iguales, racionales y con
intereses propios
aceptarían como términos
fundamentales de su asociación.
Es decir, podrían pensar que
el velo de ignorancia
no es un dispositivo eficaz
de representación
para responder la pregunta que
Rawls se propone contestar.
O bien, algunos de ustedes podrían
pensar que las personas libres,
iguales, racionales y con
intereses propios
aceptarían como términos
fundamentales de asociación
es lo que el velo de ignorancia les da,
pero no determina lo que es justo.
O bien, podrían pensar,
y consideraremos esta respuesta en
nuestra clase del jueves,
que no es el caso
que la primera virtud de las
instituciones sociales es justicia.
Pero más bien hay otros valores
incluso más fundamentales
que están en el centro de la
legitimidad política.
Regresaré a esa pregunta en
nuestra clase del jueves.